this is a Hot Chip college it hurt hey
what's going on everybody it's Sean
Evans host of first we feast hot ones
and for the past week I've just been
getting non-stop tweets about this Pocky
one chip challenge it's a chip
it's made with the world's hottest
pepper Carolina Reaper and it is all
over the place it's on the internet I
see it on TV
shout out to Al Roker for just sitting
there like a G just churning his straw
is milk like it's no big deal
while Billy Bush's face caves in on
itself anyway what we're going to do the
pocky one chip challenge you knew it was
only a matter of time before hot ones
took its swing and because I have a
freakish tolerance I brought along two
of my best friends in the office along
for the ride the boss lady nadeska
Alexis is here my dear friend Emily
Oberg
and so let's go into this unboxing whoa
you've got a lot going on
these are sweat fans literally sweater
and a sturdy where should we wear these
there's any kind of BuzzFeed ish yeah
Cooper oh and some Tom's so the honey I
don't understand honey because it'll be
it's a good uh good for your mouth and
your mouths on fire I'm an abysmal so a
lot working here this seems excessive
sharp alright - here is the pocky chip
it's made with a Carolina Reaper and
there's only one in each package
sometimes start eating the entire chip
this litt looks dangerous
hmm it's so like okay right smelling it
I know it's gonna be very hot though so
mate yeah what God nadeska nice what
being going into my mouth are we taking
like half the chip right now you got to
finish this chip but not in one bite
it's the one chip challenge on the
challenge you're gonna eat it all at one
yeah I'm just gonna fill this thing yeah
go for it maybe guys cheers Cheers
it's not bad
so I known the hot ones guy I'm supposed
to put up a very hard front on this this
is a Hot Chip so very hot chip yeah
what's going through your at first is
mild it creeps up on you and it's
getting stronger by the minute
Sam because it's a chip it's kind of
like in your teeth I'm kind of like in
like I feel like this gonna take a while
milk okay
vicious growl is it like patting I think
I smell too much meat in it like hits
the spot where they like they'll leave
smoke it's me Shh so it stings but other
than that it's a great really not that
bad wait are you serious I'm dying it's
okay to recap whoa nadeska there's
probably most nervous going in hey don't
call me nervous but I had the most
reservations going in yeah took the most
persuading yeah cool no big deal my fat
Emily talk to little hot sauce trash
before hey oh my god it hurt College it
hurt I feel warmer I was really cold all
day in the office so I'd even take my
jacket off oh my god I care a little
showing you this take it or that or that
so here's I'll say about the Pocky chew
as advertised if you really want to
smoke your face out with one bite this
is the way to do it still on my tongue
still on my throat a pretty tough chip
to endure and this is from a guy who's
had two Carolina Reapers who takes that
extra dab of Blair's Megadeth sauce with
liquid rage shout-out to Pocky can
correct the coffin is fitting a very hot
chef am i righty Sean [ __ ] you